So let's take a step back to a Roswell. We talked about a little bit.
What's your sense about that whole time of Roswell and just area 51
and, um,
the sightings and also the follow on mythology around
those sightings. Um, that's with us today.
All right. So, well, I mean,
it is a mythology here, right? The mythology of Roswell it's,
it's very religious,
like in the sense that if there's a pilgrimage to Roswell people make,
and they go to, there's a festival there as well,
like a religious festival. Um,
you could get little kitschy stuff like you can get at a religious festival
there.
So it's very much like a place of pilgrimage where a [inaudible] occurred.
And her off me is basically contact with non-human intelligence. Okay.
So non-human intelligence is thought to have contacted humans or crashed at
this place in Roswell, New Mexico.
Now what's fascinating is that I begin my book by going out to a crash site,
New Mexico. Um, I have to get blindfolded with, um,
my well, to tell you the truth. The story is that I'm with Tyler,
who's an invisible.
And he wants to show me a place in New Mexico where a crash happened.
And he says that he thinks that I need to see physical evidence because I don't
believe. And so I said, I'll go, but I'm going to bring a friend of mine.
And he said, no, you have to go alone. He goes, it's a,
it's a place that is on government owned property.
And it's a no fly zone. And when you go, you'll be blindfolded.
And I said, I definitely need to bring a friend.
So he said, well, who do you want to bring?
I just had met this university scientist. He's very well-known.
And I call him James in my book and I asked and I had a feeling James would
definitely want to do this. And I asked James and he said, I'll go tomorrow.
Okay. So I suggested this to Tyler and Tyler say,
absolutely not. You know? And I thought, Hmm,
I know he's going to look up James. And he's going to say yes,
because if anybody can figure out what this material is that you're going to go
look for, it's going to be James. He the instruments. And so Tyler did in fact,
look them up and finally said, okay, I got, you can go.
So we both head out there and we get blindfolded. Tyler takes us out there.
It takes about 40 minutes, um, outside of a certain place in New Mexico.
So in terms of Roswell, this is what I can say is that according to Tyler,
there were about seven crashes out in the 1940s in New Mexico
and in various places, um,
we went to one of them, according to Tyler, I,
at the time I was completely an atheist with regard to anything that had to do
with UFO's. So we were out there, we had specially configured,
um, metal detectors for these metals, and we did find these.
Okay. And, um, they've since been studied by very scientist, material,
scientists, so forth. And, um,
I believe jock talked about not those particular ones,
but others on the Joe Rogan show. Um,
there are no anomalies, so there are we, uh, scientists don't, I'm, uh,
I'm not a scientist, so I can't weigh in on whether I just,
I just believe the people, these people,
I believe because they're well-known scientists.
What do you mean? They're not anomaly, so there's no, they.
Are not, they are non anomalous.
Oh.
And almost in terms of the materials that are a naturally occurring on earth.
Yes. Okay. So that,
so there's some kinda inklings of evidence that, uh,
that something happened in Roswell in
terms of crashes of alien technology. Uh,
what else is there to the mythology? So there's some crashes,
right? I mean, that's kind of Epic, whatever. And,
uh, w w what else? Like what, um, what are we supposed to take away from this,
right.
Yeah. So it's weird. Okay. So, um, there's this? Okay. So in religious studies,
like I said, we call it a, her off any,
which is the meeting of a non-human intelligent thing, whatever it is, an angel,
a God, whatever a goddess with, or an alien with humans,
and that's the place. Okay. So the place is New Mexico. So we,
so New Mexico becomes folded into the mythology of this
new religion is what I call a new type of religion, um, of the UFO.
And it becomes ground zero for this new mythology,
just like Mecca is the, is the place where Muslims go. They have to go, right.
At least once in their lives. It's a pilgrimage place now.
So this is so in my book, that's how I, I tell it now,
what about Roswell in the public imagination? Um,
obviously according to any Jacobson, who's good. You know,
she's a great author. Um, investigative journalist,
she's written about Roswell too.
I don't agree with all of what she comes up with,
but part of it is that there's a lot of military stuff going on there that is
classified, and there's a reason why you can't get in and nor would you want to.
Right. So, um, so there's a lot of experimentation going on there.
Um, I don't believe that it's has to do with ETS, frankly,
but in the imaginations of Americans, Roswell is that place.
But I went to a different place and apparently there are several places in New
Mexico. Now, strangely enough,
I traveled back to New Mexico at the very end chapter of my book,
but it's not it's, I don't, I don't go there physically.
I go there through the story of a Catholic nun
who actually believes she by located to New Mexico, uh,
in the gosh in the 16 hundreds. So she,
yeah, it was very strange.
And I was at the Vatican at the space observatory when I made that connection
that she probably went to the very well,
she believes she went to this very place that I had gone.
Can you, uh, can you elaborate in a little bit, like,
what does it mean to go to that place? So, yeah, for, for her, I mean,
it's just, we're kind of, um,
breaking down the barrier between what it means to be at a place
in time. Right.
I agree with you. Uh, this is the field of religious studies. So, and again,
I don't say it's true in my book.
I just say it's a very strange coincidence that I'm at the
Vatican observatory. In fact, I'd finished my book,
but while I was at the Vatican observatory,
I was there with Tyler and we were looking at the records,
the CA they're called the trial records,
but they're the canonization records of these two saints.
Each was said to have done amazing things.
One was Joseph of Cupertino who levitated, okay.
Is said to have levitated. The other was Maria of agritech from Spain,
their contemporaries in the 16 hundreds who were said to have been able to buy
locate, which is to be in two places at once. Okay.
So this is a belief in Catholicism that certain,
very Holy people can do these kinds of things like levitate, which by the way,
is also associated with UFO abductions. You know,
people get levitated out of their beds and things like that.
So we were sent there, um,
by a billionaire who was interested in levitation and by
location. And since I could get in to the Vatican,
and I knew the director of the Vatican observatory,
both Tyler and I were able to go to the secret archives and look at the
canonization records and then go to castle Gandolfo,
which is about an hour from the Vatican where the first observatory,
the space observatory of the Vatican is the second one.
And it is in Arizona. And it has a much larger telescope. So we went and we,
and brother, guy gave me the keys to the archive. I said,
look at anything you want. And I got to see a lot of stuff by Carl Sagan,
by the way, I know you talked about, yeah, it was awesome.
So they have a whole section on extra terrestrial,
the search for extra terrestrial life and they don't by the way. Awesome.
It was awesome. Yeah. So we.
Got to stay there. They have a scholars quarters, and so they had to,
and so Tyler stayed and Wayne and I stayed in the other and brother guy
probably shouldn't have been so nice to me and given me the, um, the keys,
because I, when I got home, we were there for two weeks. When I got home,
I got this frantic phone call from him and he basically said, Diana, he goes,
do you remember where you put the, the original Kepler?
And so I had this Kepler, right. And so I misplaced it.
Luckily.
I remembered where it went. I was like, Oh gosh, thank goodness I found it,
but he'll probably change the rules of the Vatican observatory after my visit.
So Maria is, um,
she's actually in the history of our country in that she
first wrote a Cosmati graphy of, um,
what she said was the spinning earth.
And this was in the 16 hundreds and she that's her first book.
And she wrote that.
And then she said that she was transported on the wings
of angels to the new world.
And she said that she met a culture of people and
she basically told them about the faith of Catholicism. Okay.
And then what happened was that the people that sh and she described the fauna,
she described the people and everything like that.
And so there were actually missionaries there.
And when they went to try to, um,
convert some of the people who already lived there, um,
apparently they already knew a bunch of stuff. And they said,
how did you know all this stuff? And they said, uh,
this lady in blue came and told us, and they said, did it look like this?
And they showed them, they didn't obviously didn't have a photograph,
but they had a picture of a, a sister, a nun. And they say,
yeah, they, she works similar clothes, but she was much younger. Right.
And these guys were, you know, thought that was weird.
But when they went back to Spain,
they found that this woman had been doing that in her mind had been traveling.
I mean, I don't know what to make of it.
There's so many things that are sort of forcing you to kind of go outside of,
um, you know, I'm of many minds. I've very,
most of my days spent with very rigorous scientific kind of things
and even engineering kind of things. And then I'm also open-minded.
And just the,
the entirety of the idea of extraterrestrial life forces you to think outside
of, uh,
conventional boundaries of thought scientific, current scientific thought,
let's put it that way and your story now. So the example of that, yeah.
That's a nice way to put it.